Khloe Kardashian would like to report a
robbery
well kind of own whatever it is because
her five-year-old daughter true Thompson
stole her mama's Glam Squad
the scene of the crime true's fifth
birthday party
yeah for the cuties backyard bash she
took a page out of Coco's book hijacking
mom's hair and makeup team to serve all
that five and fabulous energy but that's
the fun of it Chloe's longtime hair
stylist Andrew Fitzsimons posted a pic
of true's Tresses calling her my
favorite client for sure Coco responded
PSA Andrew won't work with me anymore he
left me for true isn't that crazy but
get this Drew didn't just snatch Andrew
she also took Chloe's makeup artist Ash
Chloe joked true I love you babe but I
have to teach you how you never take
someone's Glam team we all want to be
cute over here now with this family it's
no surprise that true caught the Glam
bug true you know this
me mama
can I see you
yeah earlier this month Coco shared a
home video of her little one giving
herself a messy makeover I turned around
for two seconds I was like I'm just
gonna go to my room and grab something
and I come back I'm like oh my gosh like
she was having a field day I was like
okay well at least we're in the Glam
room and I'm going to be okay everything
I could wipe down but you know look at
that face how could you be mad it's
adorable has she ever tried to paint
your face with oh all the time and
you've got to let them do it I know I
love kids to be kids so I let them do
their thing I am so obsessed with her
and I love it so much she's super into
makeup oh yeah she is she's into makeup
and she I like her to explore and do her
thing I mean at this age they don't
really know they think it's just like
face painting and yeah fun stuff that
drives me crazy which Echoes what Chloe
told E.T in 2019. she uh was playing
with highlighter earlier today and I was
like I don't know if this is okay but
it's it's getting me to finish getting
rest today so we'll clean her up later
but she looks really good sparkly
through clearly the apple of her mama's
eye my favorite part about being a mom I
mean it's so corny but it's just like no
matter how tired you are whatever you
just it's complete Bliss but true if
you're listening maybe next time spare
your mom and borrow Glam from one of
your aunties Bible
foreign